that my question to Christians now is
that you're a Christian which means to
be christ-like that's your faith right
what was the faith of Jesus Christ you
will be pointing up even my own
daughter at nine years old would look at
me and be like that makes no sense as
Jesus grew up to learn more and more
about God
Jesus Is God how can you learn more and
more about himself yeah the Moroccan
players prostrating prostrating not only
when they won but when they lost
[Applause]
all alone
and his final Messengers Muhammad peace
be upon him this is our religion Islam
Islam this is the beach
and I was explaining how much respect I
have for the faith
and guess who I have with me here
it's one of the original guests talking
about very important topic back then it
was SD and today we're in HD 4K isn't it
yeah 4K now
you're all grown up now now we're old
it's been a long time I've met about
what 16 years since the first appearance
on the dean show I I cannot tell you how
many times just recently I had a
Croatian or was he Serbian he approached
me this is in the mosque in MEC in
Chicago
and he came up and he said you know I
watched this show that you did and he
said I watched that top 10 reasons why
Jesus wasn't God he was on his quest
searching yeah you know searching
purpose of life and that came across
and in his search and that was a trigger
point that really stuck with him and he
actually he accepted his line Masha
Allah yeah you never know you do
something 15 20 years ago how it trickle
effect of it being out there that was
the whole beauty of why we started doing
all this stuff in the first place we
were talking about earlier today you
know that I started my dad on MySpace
that's where you know as first because I
knew his the more you put out there the
more you know opportunity people have to
come across it and we might be dead in
our Graves and somebody finds a video
that we've done and they accept the slam
so it's it's all a way of putting out
Good Deeds that could be it's like
throwing out a bunch of fishing nets you
know I mean you never know when a fish
is going to come along and hit it yes
so uh how's uh how's everything how's uh
everything been we're always good as
Muslims you know the world is uh rapidly
changing and evolving and and um you
know we have to do our our best to to
continue to be on the front lines of of
helping people understand the truth
about their purpose and their nature
because one of the things is you know
Islam is to teach us about our true
purpose in nature right that's that's
the whole point is first to understand
who we truly are in retrospect of the
Creator and the creation
and we live in a world now that is it's
entire it seems like the entire job of
the world now is to confuse people about
who they are what their identity is
pronouns changing weekly like nobody
knows who they are anymore and as
Muslims this is where we are able to put
out that flag and be that hold fast of
who we are as human beings that we are
servants to the Creator he created us
perfectly he created us exactly how he
wanted us to be we don't need to be
anything other than that we serve and
worship him and then that's how we live
a beautiful life in this world in the
next so I think you know we have it even
greater opportunity now to tell people
about Islam but the odds are becoming
more and more stacked it's just reality
and we're not the only Faith group
that's seeing that you know identity
politics or at play everywhere let's go
back to this key figure that now there's
a divide there but it seems like people
are
from the statistic they said that 52
percent of Christians don't believe
Jesus Is God and that's when we first
met we talked a lot about Jesus we
talked about Islam in the Bible and then
you did the top 10 reasons why Jesus is
not God yep
um has anything changed from those top
ten there now that we have you know
opportunity to meet again is there when
you approach Christians you know do you
still use those the same talking points
there with this or have you I mean the
top ten was was a very zealous attempt
to be very specific
um you know as you get older one of the
things we learn as we get older we learn
how to to be more pragmatic about our
approaches to certain things so I I am
more of an approach I've always taken
the approach that the more you get
people to think on their own the more
easy they are to come to valid opinions
you know I mean self-discovery is unlike
being anything else it's not like me
telling you something it's asking
questions we said that when we just went
and visited uh the the dean Center not
too long ago we need to do this for the
future of our children the future of our
great country the future of mankind this
is
and I've got a very important message
alhamdulillah brother Eddie is setting
up the dean enter not just the dean show
but the dean Center a full dawa Academy
a Masjid a dawa Center in America the
first of its type the a groundbreaking
project and I want everybody as I'm
supporting it I want everybody to
support it so we can take the dawa to
the next level we need the dean Center
please support it
that my question to Christians now is
that you're a Christian which means to
be christ-like that's your faith right
what was the faith of Jesus Christ that
was that really stuck with me so you're
you have faith in Jesus you have faith
in Jesus what was his faith what was
Jesus's Faith was his faith in himself
you know and then when you go and look
at the Bible and I did a video on my
YouTube not too long ago about this why
I left Christianity because it really
boiled down boiled down to three points
the person of Jesus and the validity of
the Bible without those two things
Christianity is literally just falls
into nothing even even Paul himself said
without Christ crucified our faith is in
vain like we have nothing so I encourage
Christians now more to what was the
faith of Jesus like now you can tell me
what your faith is your pillars I
believe in Jesus Christ died on the
cross that okay so if your faith is
completely dependent upon Jesus
crucifixion what was his faith
for his entire life until this point
what was his faith there's going to be a
knee-jerk reaction someone's going to
say well that's obvious he was Christian
because I'm Christian he was Christian
so he was himself to be Christian means
to be christ-like to be like Christ to
be a follower of Christ just like
Muslims we don't call ourselves
muhammadins we don't call ourselves
follow the Muhammad we follow his
religion his religion was Islam so we
are Muslims just like he was so if you
look at the faith of Jesus Christ he was
asked he was asked simply
about his faith and it was actually a
trick question
when he was asked what is the greatest
commandment because really in reality
there's no there's no greatest
commandment they're all equal
um and he said I can't tell you the
greatest commandment without telling the
first commandment the first commandment
is hero is with the Lord your God is one
uniquely one love you the Lord your God
with all your heart with all your might
with all your strength love your
neighbor like you love yourself he said
all of the law of God and all the
prophets hang on these principles that
was the Faith of Christ
so I asked Christians that was his faith
is that how you define your faith if not
then there is a problem there is a
problem you are not christ-like
because the term didn't exist at that
time no did not exist it did not exist
that's a really important point of
information something to have something
during his life nobody called themselves
a Christian his followers did not call
him the the the disciples did not call
themselves Christians so what were they
so what's the next step usually when you
get people to think about this and then
they're like that's like an aha moment
where do you take it from there I tell
them that the faith of Jesus was the
same as the faith of Moses was the same
as Faith with David was the same of
faith that Abraham used to believe in
one God Alone that is the core tenet
foundational principle of God and it has
always been the same and I tell them
forget about you know what what what
what is written in the New Testament and
Paul go all the way back to getting
started genome it's Deuteronomy look at
what God says about himself he's one
he's uniquely one he's jealous you know
he does not like it took anything other
than him to be worshiped that is very
simple across the board that is the
faith of Jesus that is the faith of
Muslims we have not changed anything
that's the whole point is that nothing
changes and this is the theory that we
as Muslims have about God is that he is
does not change if God can change we're
all doomed you know I mean he is the one
absolute like stable factor in the
universe is that he is who he is and
that does not change therefore as a
Muslim I have the same faith that Jesus
Christ peace upon him had when he walked
this Earth I love the Lord my God with
all of my heart with all of my might and
all of my strength that is in Islam
called uh the rights that belong to
Allah the rights that belong to him
you know these are the pillars they're
given to God and then second pillar of
Islam which was the second pillar Jesus
taught you love your neighbor like you
love yourself meaning you treat other
people the way you want to be treated
this in Islam is known as the rights
they belong to the creation and that is
the entirety of the religion of Islam I
tell people that if you take Islam as a
concept and you wanted to divide it into
two main categories those two main
categories are the rights that belong to
Allah God alone and the rights that
belong to creation and that is Islam and
that's what Jesus taught so I get them
on that that that thought process that
if you want to be like Jesus then you
have to be like Jesus you can't you
can't go and be like Paul or be like any
of these other disciples or your
preacher you have to look at what Jesus
taught what what he preached what were
the commands he gave to the people
around him at his time and you follow
those
it reminds me of a verse from the
verbatim word of God Almighty Allah the
Quran when you mentioned the prophets
were Allah is saying God Almighty is
saying the Creator is saying that
regarding Abraham that he wasn't a Jew
or a Christian but he was one who
submitted his will to the one God yeah
and he was known as hanif hanif hanif
which means like purity of faith for one
God like uprightness Purity like he gave
everything absolutely to God Alone they
belonged to him and and that that is the
religion of of of of of all the prophets
he didn't worship Jesus no for sure he
didn't worship himself or the creation
or anything he worshiped like Muslims do
like we do today the Creator the Creator
that is it and there is only one Creator
and everything else other than that is
part of his creation and those two
cannot be equal no one would say no one
of the right mind who thinks property
would say that the Creator is like the
creation these two things are are
separate this is where Paul had to break
this idea and say that God became a man
you know uh Christ became flesh you know
like us and but you if you look at it
realistically there's the Creator and
there's the creation these two are not
equal and they're not the same even
Jesus said it that I do nothing of my
own like I don't have
any power except that which the father
has given me he works through me the
Miracles that that he that I do I don't
do them by myself so it's it's it's
really comes down to to stripping away
preconceived notion Notions and looking
at the faith of Jesus Christ and and
this is also part of Islam and Muslims
I've been now the you know it's been 17
years since we did these videos Almost
um even with Muslims we have
unfortunately a lot of preconceived
notions about religion that become very
culturally ingrained into the faith and
for me as as a a convert revert wherever
you want to say it I have been able to
see outside that Paradigm so it's the
same concept is that Islam is pure and
simple and logical to worship God alone
and follow his Commandments everything
other than that is is not part of the
religion and therefore we strip all of
that away you find what worship God
alone that's it give God his rights give
human beings our rights
and and and Live and Let Live
um so that's that's kind of been my more
pragmatic approach towards Christianity
now rather than you know just taking
attacks at at the Bible taking a tax at
Paul they get very defensive and and
defensive people are usually not very
receptive so it's more of just asking
them questions of
Woody what do you believe in what is
your faith and then what was Jesus of
faith
see if you the two are congruent with
one another what you happen to what a
lot of people come to find out that your
faith is Pauline
that's when you get down to the crust of
the matter the Crux of the matter is the
only person who taught your faith is
Paul the Apostle who never met Jesus who
never walked with him who never talked
to him none of these things but this is
not the faith of Jesus Christ the faith
that Jesus Christ was to worship God
Alone that was it he himself was still
considered considered himself a
practicing part of the faith of the
children Israel at the time which was
monotheism he still went to the
synagogue he still he fought against all
of the things that were going on he
never established he didn't go into step
building a whole new building called
people into it and say worship me this
does not happen you would figure
you would figure if your entire
salvation right
in the entirety of your salvation
reliant on you worshiping Jesus Christ
then why for 33 years of his life did he
never build a building
call people in there and say worship me
and you will go to heaven like this
makes no sense God is not the Bible says
God is not the author of confusion why
did it take at least 13 to 15 years
later for Paul to start teaching us as a
Doctrine like this makes no common sense
whatsoever it just does not sound
logical the faith that Jesus was to
worship God so if you want to be
Christian which means to be like Christ
then you would worship God
simple as that
that's deep I mean it's something
straightforward it's easy to digest easy
to understand
and uh inshallah that people can go
ahead and you know I feel that a lot of
times if a person is is open-minded and
they're sincerely looking for the truth
because the the innate nature of the
human re being rejects this idea of God
being a man you know this whole concept
of the Trinity doesn't make sense uh God
dying for your sins coming down to earth
and a lot of these things are very
emotional I can die at all yeah
and and this is the problem is a lot of
Christians think that Muslims are are
like reject Jesus and that's that's so
contradictory to what we actually
believe and actually in order to be a
Muslim you must have full faith in Jesus
Christ that is a pillar of our religion
if someone were to come and say I'm
Muslim but I don't believe in Jesus then
the latter statement contradicted the
first one you cannot be a Muslim without
full faith in Jesus Christ his virgin
birth you know his uprightness you can't
you cannot be a Muslim without these
things so we actually are people who are
affirm Jesus Christ but to think that on
the day of judgment
that God is going to punish people for
worshiping him alone that makes no sense
it makes no sense to think that okay
let's just let's let's set a
hypothetical scenario I'm a Muslim I go
in front of God on the day of judgment
why did you do what you did I worshiped
you because alone because that's the way
I I saw Abraham worshiped you that's the
way I saw Noah worship you that's the
way I saw David worship you that's the
way I saw Jesus worshiped you
and you're going to tell me that God is
going to throw me into Eternal fire for
worshiping him alone
this makes no sense it's so
contradictory but I can prove to you
that God says he will punish those who
worship anything other than him it's in
the very first law of Deuteronomy hero
Israel I the Lord your God I'm one and
have no other God before me make thyself
no grave in images worship don't worship
anything else other than me I am a
jealous God
so I can have much proof to that but
there is nowhere you can say to me that
you can prove in any point in any place
that worshiping God Alone will in one in
Eternal destruction
that is why Islam is the only pure
monotheistic religion on the face of the
planet Earth today because we worship
God Alone singularly uniquely only and
we don't worship anything else other
than him
we make that distinction that there is a
Creator and then there's the creation
and those two are not the same yes it's
a it's really amazing because a lot of
times uh religion has been left to
something that is esoteric for many
people it's just mysterious but then
it's not supposed to make sense a lot of
times you know it's yeah you can't
understand God but here you're talking
and it's kind of like hold on this is
too simple it's it's just it's common
sense is it supposed to be that simple
it's supposed to be that simple because
God is just therefore if if religion was
esoteric and only able to be understood
by enlightened Minds then what about the
rest of the unenlightened world they
don't have access to God God is supposed
to be readily accessible to anyone with
any
capacity of understanding even the
person with the most diminished capacity
of understanding can understand the
concept there's one God there's no more
else there's nothing else there's one
that's a very simple concept to
understand but you try to explain the
concept of of uh you know paganism many
gods and all these warring gods or even
the concept of the trinity you know that
there's one God who's in three unique
personages these personages are all the
same person but they're not the same
person and they're they're equal but
they're not equal
even my own
daughter at nine years old would look at
me and be like that makes no sense as
Jesus grew up he learned more and more
about God
Jesus Is God how can you learn more and
more about himself
because Jesus is God
it's a great question so how can you
learn more and more about himself
because it said Jesus grew up he learned
more and more about God his father
well because when Jesus came down to
earth
he grew up as a regular human being too
so he would read the Bible and that kind
of thing
about himself she heard me doing she
heard me doing my why I left
Christianity because it's in in my
basement she heard me she was like did
you just say that God was three and one
and one and three but they were all the
same and not the same I was quoting the
Apostles Creed that the thought that God
the father is God the son and God the
son is God the Holy Spirit but the holy
spirit is not the father the father she
was like that doesn't make any sense I'm
like I know it doesn't this is not how
the religion to worship God and the path
to Heaven is supposed to be supposed to
be simple you worship God and you try to
do what's right that doesn't mean by
doing what's right you're going to go to
paradise but that's how you earn the
Forgiveness of God
now you can't give all of your sins to
one person and have them all wiped away
because if that was the concept why
can't I do that in any other thing why
can't I go to a criminal court and say
you know what Jesus died for my sins you
know 2000 years ago I don't know why I'm
even up here I should not even be being
tried for this you can't do that it does
not work that way so we know logically
it doesn't work therefore it's not going
to work and the adjustment in front of
God either wow subhanallah this is uh
really how have you kept such a
longevity now many people you know it's
been like you just mentioned 17 years
has just passed like that yeah what do
you even do to get people to thinking uh
like you just said most people are
leaving a lot of even Christians are
getting fed up with the church because
they're seeing a lot of
compromised and seeing people
compromising they're getting fed up and
somewhere even because of that
gravitating towards Islam they're saying
you know that Islam we can see you know
it's starting to make sense why is Islam
is so
um the Purity as far as like keeping
certain things and certain Lifestyles
that are there that are unacceptable and
that God has to be obeyed it's clear you
can't you know compromise in your faith
and people are starting to respect that
especially what's going on with this
whole gender fluidity and uh trying to
sexualize politics yeah all of this yeah
well that's one of the Fatal flaws
within Christianity and this is not to
take a dig at anyone it's just this is a
fatal flaw within the system one of the
Fatal flaws in Christianity is there's
no there's no
code there's no Creed if you say you
believe in Jesus having died on the
cross for your sins then you are a
person of paradise like you're going to
heaven no matter what else happens in
your life you're still saved and and
that becomes very problematic because it
allows a lot of fluidity allows you to
compromise on a lot of things that you
normally wouldn't compromise on with it
whereas within Islam we have a a coded
system of how we are supposed to apply
the religion within our lives therefore
we could there are certain boundaries we
cannot go past and if we do go past them
it's considered like a mortal sin you
know I mean in front of God and
therefore Muslims are it the world is
very quickly finding out especially with
the World Cup and all that that happened
Around the World Cup the world is is is
is is very quickly finding out that
Muslims are some of the last holdouts of
principled religion that's what I
consider Islam a principled religion
every other religion has its you know
it's it's loopholes and once saved
always saved I don't really have to do
anything I just have to believe in Islam
it's a parental religion because we not
only believe certain things but we have
to do certain things and we have to stay
away from certain things in order to to
live a righteous life so we are one of
the very last principled moral holdouts
on the planet Earth today yeah did you
get a chance to see it seems like when
um since you mentioned the world cup
with you had Morocco who was coming
close and then you had Muslims who are
throwing up just like you had the famous
fighter khabib he would be pointing up
yep and this signifies the pure
monotheism that we're talking about that
Jesus was upon and all the prophets one
one guy the pure monotheism taheed and
then the Moroccan play as prostrating
prostrating not only when they won but
when they lost but then you had this uh
German Outlet on a few scene they were
trying to come aboard and say look there
they were trying to connect the team to
this group daesh and they were saying
yeah did you see that when they say it's
an Isis symbol yeah how would you
respond to that because they were
throwing up the so that means Habib and
all the Muslims in the world us were
throwing up one one God Jesus would have
been throwing up one God they're all how
low can you go
these are coming from people who don't
even who can't Define genders you know I
mean they can't tell you what a male and
female that's where it is you know I
mean so like I don't really what do you
expect from what do you expect from
these type of people you know I mean
they're they're their identity politics
are the flavor of the week it's like
going to Baskin Robbins you know I mean
which some people might be watching not
know what Baskin Robbins is but it's a
ice cream story here in America we can
go and there's like 32 Flavors and they
have a flavor of the week that's it you
can go in and just pick whatever flavor
you like today and for Muslims we can't
do that we have principled and and the
most the number one principle in Islam
is that's it you cannot worship anything
other than God like everything else is
forgivable in the Quran it says that God
forgives all sins like I literally
anything else is forgivable except for
worshiping something other than him that
is where Muslims become so principled
and no matter what else we might do
because you can't judge our religion
based on its adherence that's that's
that's just common sense to not do but
our principles is that any Muslim you go
to that is is a practicing Muslim you'll
ask him what is your belief I believe in
one God that's it it's simple I believe
in one God there is no there's no way to
confuse that principle and that is where
we have to make our stand is that we are
principal people who believe in one God
and we follow what he wants us to do
that's it hence the that's it it means
once one that's it and then uh from
there you see it's it's a symbol of of
saying one ahead yeah or or or or
Asha in the Hebrew language was what
Jesus would have said you had so many
people now they were
for years being bombarded with all the
negative hype they went down to this
part of the world and you can hear them
testifying that you know the hospitality
the kindness and then also seeing you
know the Muslim players you know you see
them uh one in particular he's hugging
his mother you know with respect to
parents and we don't really you're
starting to lose that and uh it's part
of the world yep and and it's and it's
sad that there's going to be you know
there's such long periods of time before
the next World Cup because if it was
like maybe next year or two years from
now it's hosted here next time you know
that coming to America yeah yeah it
would be nice to see if you put that
side to see the difference that'd be
really nice how much of a difference is
going to be from let's say Somebody went
to the World Cup in Qatar and now go to
the World Cup in America and tell me the
difference between the two experiences
because I don't know what they haven't
decided what city is going to host it
yet but America has it next yeah because
just from you know the the
prohibition of alcohol restricting it
there people were actually like you know
segregations the segregate yes even
women women from having their own they
were happy to go into and be patted down
by females and have men groping all over
you there was even that one reporter for
Fox News that was very irritated about
yes having to go through it's like you
want to be grouped by strange men like
that's the type of idea that you're
portraying like I want to go in a line
yeah like I think of my own daughter
like what I want my daughter to go in a
line yeah with men how I don't know what
they are what they're thinking what
their intentions are feeling all on my
daughter like
and they call that freedom
they call that freedom and it's and it's
it's just it's like they want us to
believe white is black black is white
night is Day Day is night yeah and this
was that also a a prophecy of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him that
door's the end of times things will
become flipped the truth will be known
as falsehood and false to be known truth
the liar really knows the truth from the
truth will be known as a liar you
wouldn't know what's right and what's
wrong because they would flip and this
is like what's happening now to be a
principled moral person is you're the
bigot you're the racist you're the this
but you know I mean if I'm just Kumbaya
with anything and everything oh this is
an enlightened person a moderate uh
Progressive that's Progressive that's I
don't see progression in that so it's a
good spending a little bit of time with
you always a pleasure you're going to be
uh doing a tour in UK right yes people
want to come see you down there two
months I will be posting the uh the the
tour schedule shortly inshallah yeah all
over the UK
look forward to inshallah look forward
to having you back uh in Florida get
back here in this nice is everybody can
see we have the palm trees and the nice
weather we gotta and tomorrow I'm gonna
be going back and shoveling snow
excuse more to come out here the more
the warm weather look forward to it
inshallah thank you always my pleasure
brother likewise
and sisters I am here in Tampa Florida
in front of the future Dean Center which
would be the first mega dawa Center in
America brothers and sisters Allah has
privileged you and I with the truth and
this is an opportunity for us to do a
prophet's work and earn a prophet's
reward the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that this is a
matter that will reach every home and
now is your opportunity to be involved
in such a thing that the prophet
Muhammad
prophesies which will impact hundreds
and millions of people and generation
after generation to come donate right
now click the link below may Allah
reward all of you
foreign
[Music]